hi there if you play chess you'll
probably recognize
the following moves as illegal
in the top row pawns move two squares at
a time
while they are not on their home row in
the bottom row you'll see a pawn
moving backwards and another one moving
sidewards even
so in classical chess these moves are
illegal but there are variants of chess
where these moves aren't illegal where
they are actually explicitly
part of the rules these are alternate
chess rules and this paper is about
exploring
those rules what happens if you
implement those rules how does the game
play
change and what can we learn for general
games so the paper here is called
assessing game balance with alpha zero
exploring alternative rule sets in chess
by nina thomasev ulrich paquette
demis hospice and vladimir kramnik
uh the former three of deepmind and the
latter is
was the world chess champion for these
eight years depicted
so the paper tries to bring together
two different worlds first it is
the chess world so a lot of this paper
is explicitly about
the game of chess if you don't play
chess
or if you occasionally play chess like
myself
this might not be the most interesting
paper
though it contains some really
interesting kind of bits
the other world is the reinforcement
learning world which you'll see
in the alpha zero name right here so
the reasoning behind this is the
following chess is a really
really old game and rules have evolved
over time and have sort of consolidated
on the rules we have today
but also strategy has evolved over time
and
lots and lots of thinking and theory has
gone into the strategy of chess
and to change the rules around um
you can change the rules of chess
however
you can't really assess how the game
would be played by humans
uh if the rules were changed because you
don't have a thousand years
of the entire humanity studying these
new rule sets and
therefore you're kind of stuck with
assessing the games from the perspective
of someone who has learned the old rules
but reinforcement learning to the rescue
so consider the following rule changes
no castling this is a really simple rule
change
no castling castling is disallowed
throughout the game
if you don't know what castling is
castling is like a special move
where there is this rook and the king
is right here i don't know how to the
king and if there's nothing in between
they can
sort of swap positions it's called
castling
uh it's a special move that you can do
and it allows you
to bring the king to the outside where
the king is safe
and to bring the rook to the inside
where
it can potentially cause a lot of damage
so it's
a very very favored move by a lot of
players
and no castling the rule change
probably alters the game a lot because
if you think of the chess board
kings start about here they can only
move one square at a time
so to get them to safety will require
like four
or five um steps for them while you have
to move everything else out of the way
including the rook that stands here so
players might elect to just leave their
kings where
they are but then they can't really open
up in the middle as much because that
would leave their kings
exposed so it is fair to assume that
just introducing this one rule might
change the games around
quite a bit how the game is played
but as we said we don't know this is
from someone
who has learned classic chess and all
the grandmasters that we have have
played and learned classic chess so how
do we assess this
this paper says that alpha zero
can be used to assess these new rules
so alpha zero is a reinforcement
learning algorithm
that can learn these board games very
very quickly
in within one day or so and it can
learn them so well it can beat humans at
the game
easily in fact modern
modern grand masters and so on use these
algorithms in order to learn and to
better their play in order to expand
their
theory their knowledge of the game to
play better against other
humans so alpha zero
imagine alpha 0 can solve a game to
perfection
what we could do is we could simply give
this rule to alpha 0 together with the
all the other chess rules
and then let alpha 0 solve the game give
it a day and
50 billion gpus solve the game
to perfection and then look at what
alpha zero came up with
kind of look at the games how they turn
out and
um whether or not they are more
interesting
less interesting longer shorter and so
on so that's
that's what this paper does so there's
the implicit assumption
which you need to believe in order to
believe anything in this paper
is that alpha zero actually has this
ability
there is pretty good evidence that it
does because of zero cans of classical
chess
and go and shogi and a bunch of other
board games
um all with the same hyper parameters
it can solve them such that it is easily
at superhuman
power so but you need to recognize that
this
is an assumption so what is alpha zero
if you don't know what alpha zero is
alpha zero
is a reinforcement learning algorithm
but not
in the kind of base reinforcement
learning sense it is a reinforcement
algorithm
that has a planner included what do i
mean by this
so if you are in a let's consider the
game tic-tac-toe
so alpha zero for tic-tac-toe in
tic-tac-toe you have this board
and you have a situation where let's say
you play your opponent plays this and
now you're tasked of playing something
you wonder should i play maybe here or
here or here where should i play
so what you can do is you can train a
reinforcement learning algorithm you
can do q learning what not okay that
will maybe
work what's better to do is
you can plan so in planning what you
want to do is you want to build a tree
of possibilities
so we're going to consider all your
possibilities and in this case you have
eight possibilities so we want to
consider
all the eight possibilities and i'm
going to draw
just some of them so up here you're
going to consider the possibility that
you place
here and here you're gonna consider the
possibility
that you place in a different spot right
here
okay and you can see how this goes so if
you want to plan
and here you have your opponent has
seven possibilities
and here your opponent also has seven
possibilities and so on so
you get this entire tree of play
but if you could do that and if you
could do that to the end
then you could easily simply choose the
path here
where you win okay where um
no matter what your opponent does you
win you can find such a path if it is
possible at all to win which
is not in tic-tac-toe right if everyone
plays optimally
it results in a draw but
let's say you could win you could choose
the path that gives you the best result
and that's it there's no learning
involved okay
so alpha zero works with a planner and
planners usually construct a tree so in
an abstract way
you are in a situation and you consider
all your options and with all your
options you consider again
all your options and so on and you do a
tree search
now this tree in tic-tac-toe it's
already huge
as you can see um in something like
chess
it is way way huger okay and
therefore it's not possible to actually
search the entire tree
because you need to consider every
single possible future
situation from the board position where
you're in
right this here is the board position
where you're in
and this is the future
the entire future of the game so every
single possibility
so alpha zero uses this thing called a
monte carlo tree search
it has several components so it's first
component and they right here they have
a description and it's very short
alpha zero this is alpha zero this is
what it does it's
like this is almost comically short so
what you do
is you put your state so s is your state
okay s is it's the board as you have it
right now
okay this here that's
this is s okay you put this into a
neural network and the neural network
gives you two things first of all it
gives you p
and and v so that's the second thing
so v will simply give you a number v
will tell you that this thing right here
is about a plus
0.5 maybe so it says
so plus one is winning and minus one is
losing uh and it is this is called the
value
so maybe it says well this position i'm
going to expect
you to win uh roughly
75 of the time right which in
expectation would be a value of positive
0.5
here because 75 percent of the time you
win
and the rest you lose let's say there is
no draw in tic-tac-toe
so there's this value function and the
second thing
is this p and the p is a policy function
so the p will and i've drawn this a
little bit
maybe not super super duper
too large but the p will tell you
for every possible move you could make
which one should you consider even okay
so it maybe it assigns this here
a point three and this here a point
four but this here is like a point zero
zero zero one
and so on so for every possible move
that you could do
it will assign a number and it's a
distribution so these numbers add up to
one but that's not important it
tells you which moves you should even
consider
going forward right so p in this case
is a distribution over the next moves
and
with those two things together we can
reduce our
tree search quite a bit so now
instead of expanding all the tree let's
go back to the tree right here
you can ask your p hey p
which one of these three should i even
consider
and maybe p says you should only
consider those two
okay and then you go down and again you
ask your p
hey p which one should you consider and
p maybe says well here you should
consider those two
here you should only consider that this
one and this three over here we've we've
already discarded this
from the beginning okay so this
p right here it guides your search it
tells you
at each point which moves should you
consider
and this as you can see reduces your
tree dramatically in fact
what alpha zero does is it simply says
you have one second
of time now expand as much as you can
in this tree uh given this one second
uh of of of time budget
and the second thing is the value so
what you would have to do expanding the
tree is
always to go to the end right so you
always go to the end
where at the end you have a fully filled
board i don't know here x
so you consider every possible situation
okay
here maybe this this player wins
as you can see you always have to go to
the end
but in our case
we don't want to always go to the end
we'd rather
explore more into like more
branches than always go to the end
and this is where the value comes in so
at some point you simply say now i'm
deep enough
and now i'm going to ask my value v now
there are
slight differences with respect to alpha
go and alpha 0 and so on
but they all have in common that they
estimate the value of the intermediate
nodes
using this v model from over here um
i have v s v was green so
they use this v model from over here to
estimate at a certain depth
so v learns to look into the future so
everything that can happen from here
and it estimates and it says well from
here you maybe have a
you know a 0.5 value or maybe a negative
0.7
and so on so v learns to assign these
values
to situations to states which are these
nodes right here and p learns to suggest
things to expand that's alpha zero
and then at the end if you've expanded
the tree enough and
estimated well then you have a pretty
good idea what's going to happen in each
of the branches that you considered
right in each of these branches you look
into the future
um from you here you look into the
future here look into the future by
doing this pv
play and after
one second after you've done you know a
couple of hundred
or thousand or however many uh looks
into the future
then you have a pretty good idea for
each of the
top level actions what's going to happen
in the future and you can simply pick
the one that
has the best future for you
according to your own model so that's
what alpha zero does
not so this is how you combine planning
and neural networks
you want to do planning but you can't
because you can only go
so deep so you use
neural networks to first of all reduce
the
number of branches you consider because
the neural network will tell you which
ones are
worthy to even look at and second of all
you don't always have to plan to the end
because you can simply
ask your neural network how much an
intermediate state is
worth in expectation
and this turns out to be pretty good why
don't we do this for every single
problem
well we do for this we do need a
simulator
so you may recognize that right here i
said we consider all the possible
actions that we have
and for each action we know exactly
what's going to happen
this is only possible like in a board
game
it's not even possible in like a board
game where you have a a die to
roll or a card to draw anything that
is random there there is a way to
include this right here but
in this simple formulation we need to
know exactly with 100
certainty what is going to happen if we
take a particular action
so this is only really applicable for
the types of
full information board games where we
can
write simulators that are pretty fast
right and even then um even though
chess you know has lots of available
actions and complications it's
nowhere near the complexity of
like a let's say a modern video game or
even or the real world is is
completely out of scope for now for
these types of things
all right so that was alphago
sorry alpha zero uh which builds on
alphago of course
and uh the rules of chess
that we're going to consider using alpha
zero
are the following so there's no castling
no castling for ten moves
pawns can only move by one square
forcing a stalemate is a win rather than
a draw so
you may know this in chess if you do not
um checkmate the opponent's king but
only
put them put the king in a situation
where it cannot move
that's called that's considered a draw
and i think even in the chess community
some people want to consider this
a win
there is torpedo where pawns can move by
one or two squares
anywhere on the board and semi torpedo
where it's the same but only from the
second and the third
rank pawn back where pawns can move
backwards and
pawn sideways where pawns can move
laterally by one squares but captures
are unchanged diagonally upwards
and there is self capture where it's
possible to capture
one's own pieces so
um there are you know slight slight
details here with respect to the 50 move
rule and so on
but if you if you don't play chess
simply consider these are
changes minor in a lot of cases
minor changes to the chess rules that
make the new rules either a superset or
a subset of the original
rules but they are going to have quite
some changes
in for the play and
we're going to look at what happens so
that's the entire research setup as
you've seen
it's alpha 0 applied to these new rule
sets and
under the assumption that alpha 0 will
solve these will become master at these
games
which we can't verify we can verify in
chess because
right alpha zero can beat people that
have
trained chess for all their life we
can't verify it here so again this is an
assumption
so the first thing i want to look at
here and this is going to
play a little bit into my criticism of
this paper
it's a pretty cool paper but i do have
some concerns right here
is the following uh the following charts
so they do they do we don't consider
how you train alpha zero let's just say
you can train it
you know to whatever pretty good
performance here is
how they evaluate so they evaluate for
each variant they do
10 000 games played at
one second per move for each different
chess current
so if you remember
as we do our tree search right we expand
the tree
according to our p and we estimate the
values according to our v
and we do this for one second
in this first thing so in one second
maybe this here is the tree
so we have some sort of an understanding
of what's going to happen
in the future you can imagine if we have
more time
then we can expand this tree more and
get a much more accurate picture of what
happens in the future
okay so they do
10 000 games at one second per move but
they also in addition to
1000 games played at one
minute per move so there's 60 times more
time and you can imagine
that we'll add quite a number of nodes
here
and you know if
if your p and v would be perfect
then it wouldn't matter as much how much
time you have as long as you sort of
have enough time
but since they're not going to be
perfect since they're only neural
networks they're not
uh god or schmidt hoover um
they cannot accurately extremely
accurately predict the future so this
planning
the the more you plan the more you
actually look into the future
the bigger your tree becomes the better
moves you make
so on the left you see the distributions
of winds
losses and draws for one second per move
and on the right for one minute per move
so both white and black pieces here are
played by alpha zero so it's not alpha
zero against something else
this is playing against itself and you
can see
in uh in classic chess
it's it's quite it's quite saddening
actually um
that this game which is is so famous you
can see that
in of 10 000 plays 8
820 end in a draw which
means that if both players are super
duper good
and uh and and play you know
play against each other it most likely
is
going to be a draw and this i think is
the criticism even in human chess
is that it's not really a decisive game
in that it
ends a lot of times in a draw so
one of the motivations here would be can
we find a rule set
that is maybe more decisive so that's
one of the
investigations they do in the paper but
you can see that there are actually so
if you consider this torpedo
chess right here um there it is more
decisive as you can see
in more times either white or
black winds right here um
and there are others which are even less
decisive like pawn back so
when pawns can move back then uh players
may
just camp they like move a pawn forward
and move it back again
and that will lead to a lot of closed
plays and so on whereas torpedo
makes you move much faster you can
advance your pawns
much faster and that will probably lead
to the end much faster so if you
consider this
on the right so what changed the rules
didn't change
alpha 0 didn't change it simply changed
that we now let alpha 0
think for longer and you can see
that the decisiveness reduces
dramatically so whereas 88
resulted in a draw with one second per
move
now 98 result in a draw with one
minute per move and this
is a trend throughout these games and
that's
also what they say in the text it is to
assume
that if you let alpha zero plan for even
longer
that this trend will continue and
ultimately
whatever rule set you make the
result is going to be a draw um if
two two let's say perfect players
play against each other which is a bit
which is a bit
saddening right because um
yeah that ultimately ultimately means
that
all of these rules aren't decisive it's
only they're only decisive
due to the fact that either
um one or the other players is way
better
or or that in general that they are not
they are not perfect
um which is an appeal of the game but
there are certainly games that
are decisive even though both players
are
pretty high level i mean think of every
every competitive video game um
so yes so that's
a bit of my criticism all of this all of
this
needs to be analyzed in the background
that what's actually happening here is
that we're dealing with
imperfect decision making
due to a limit in resources
okay and this assumption now is already
a little bit
invalid right the assumption we made at
the beginning why i pointed this out is
that
alpha zero can solve these games let's
say to perfection
and here when we analyze the
decisiveness and so on it seems to be
purely
or largely a factor of
um how much time alpha zero has
to think about the moves and
these two things to me they don't really
go
go together because we don't know
if for a different rule set um you know
the training is harder
or might take longer and so on or that
this exact one second
makes a difference or not it's it's just
um there are so many variables here and
when you're dealing with
let's say imperfect systems that are not
trained to the end or evaluated in their
full potential
you're always dealing with the fact that
you stopped each
thing at some intermediate point and
that intermediate where that
intermediate point is can
influence the results drastically now
here it seems at least the ordering
isn't changed by much but um
yeah this is one let's say one criticism
the other
criticism here uh that that i would have
again is the fact that
if you consider something like torpedo
where you can move much
much faster then
yes of course uh let's say
i don't know is it more interesting
that's that's the question right here so
they look at a lot of things like
decisiveness diversity and so on
but the question is is it more or less
interesting to play and i think that's
what humans are really after and they're
sort of trying to find proxies to this
um i would argue if you play something
like torpedo the game's
maybe much faster and um so
you you get to the end faster but also
maybe might not be as interesting
even though it's it's faster uh because
your
the complexity is is less
and with respect to the decisiveness
here
so if you have a game that's faster
um you also need to take this to into
account because
here is another thing that is sort of an
arbitrary choice
as moves are determined in a
deterministic fashion given the same
condition
diversity was enforced by sampling the
first 20 plies in each game proportional
to their mcts visit counts so what does
that mean
that means that if you run alpha 0 on
the same
situation on the same tree
sorry on the same board position it will
always come up with the same move
except for parallelism inconsistencies
and so on but
it will in you know in in a lot of times
it will come up with the same
move so how do you play 10
000 games because you can just play one
game because
each game will be the same because you
simply tell alpha zero
give me your best move right so it will
just play its optimal strategy
and all the games will be exactly the
same so there's no reason why these
should come out
different so they enforce diversity by
saying
okay okay in the first 20 moves of a
game
we don't actually take the best move
right usually you have
you have this distribution at the end of
the tree search you have a distribution
where you say okay
this move right here is clearly the best
move i'm going to play this
however if this is one of the first 20
moves of the game
they say no we need a bit of diversity
uh
so we're going to sample according to
this distribution
rather than just play the best one
now this number 20. it's just
sort of decided arbitrary right and
if you consider something like torpedo
it's a faster game
so you're faster in opening faster make
and you're faster to the end game maybe
even though they say well the game
length isn't affected this much
it could just be that um you're faster
in a situation
where um you're kind of forced to do
certain moves
and maybe the difference in decisiveness
here
is simply a result of the combination of
the faster
uh moves in torpedo together with this
the fact that they just keep the 20
plies for
each game again this is something that
you need to
consider when analyzing these results
right here
and there are a number of these choices
um
right here like the one second or one
minute per move
we sample for the first 20 plies before
we play the max move
that where i think the the results of
the study right here
they have rather limited
interpretability
if you if you ask me because um
because of these of these choices now
of course they're still the results are
quite plausible believable and the idea
is really
cool to explore these rule sets but this
was this is just
my criticism right here so we'll go
through the
rest of the results pretty pretty
quickly because
a lot of people aren't chess enthusiasts
and
we'll just pick out kind of the core
messages that the paper is trying to
get across so here the
table again with respect to decisiveness
and you can see
even uh for so for classic chess it's a
white has a 50 this is the empirical
score for white under different
game conditions so 50.8 percent means
most of the time it's a draw
so white wins uh with a probability of
50.8
uh most of the time it's a draw and
you see even like the most decisive
variant torpedo right here
is a 54 only
um so
they they analyze different defenses and
how the decisiveness is with respect to
different
defenses that are not really popular
under classical
chess and the results are interesting if
you play chess
but i would say they're rather
they're kind of aha okay if you do not
play chess because they consider
individual moves and so on what
is an interesting part is um
this right here where they look at they
look at one move that in classical
chess so e4 is a very very
um popular opening where you move your e
pawn
twice for white and
nf3 is not a super
popular opening and here they compare
this in classic chess
and in no castling gesso this
thing right here is a histogram and the
histogram
shows you the log probability of opening
sequences
when you play the individual moves so
what does this mean right here if
you play e4 then the distribution
is something like this which means that
you have some sequences that have no
entropy at all
which means that once you play
e4 and maybe one move more
then it's almost it's almost determined
what you have to do according to alpha
zero
you have like no choice except play
these few
next moves um however if you play
nf3 then alpha zero says look
this distribution is much more to the
right which means
that you have a lot more options here
now again this could be because
the move is actually less decisive
because the move
leads to more balanced more interesting
situations where you can continue
however you know with many choices it
could also be
because it's simply alpha zero simply
doesn't know as well what to do because
it leads to more complicated games and
you get to give each move
one minute to evaluate alpha zero might
just not be as good
in those situations because it leads to
more complicated
situations if it could search for longer
maybe this distribution would shift over
here
just as well again we don't know because
you only give this one second or one
minute each time for both
um and again this goes under the
assumption of alpha zero as this
perfect player however back to what they
want to say here
if you do this in no castling chess you
can see that uh this
spike right here are all the these
berlin defense variants
and castling this 0 right here is a big
part of
that line if you do this in no castling
chest you can see that
these two moves now the histograms
overlap much more
which means that and in fact you can see
in the
in this number of possible moves right
here that they come
closer together so not only does the
blue shift to the right
the orange actually shifts to the left
and it basically means that whether you
open with e4 or knight
f f3 you are going to have about the
same complexity
of game the same number of moves
available to you
going from there as you can see right
here these lines are the
moves available for white and black
under the different rule sets
so in e4 here especially
as black you do not have many moves
available
as white a little bit more but also not
more
um whereas in no castling you do so
again small rule change uh big effect
on the possible moves that you have can
consider
and this is the type of
this is the type of information
that you would want to have when you
design a game
and they allude to this also at the end
here
in their conclusions so the last thing
is they also compare
the material values of the pieces here
in the different rule sets as you might
imagine
so some pieces become much more or less
valuable i find it particularly
interesting
that if you do something like pawn
sideways
or then where the pawns are much more
powerful
of course all the other pieces drop in
value again these results are pretty
plausible so i don't want to trash the
paper right here
because it seems like it seems like the
the results are as i say plausible
and can give some cool insights so
the chess master also gives um
gives his opinions on these different
strategies that alpha zero comes up with
for the different
rules and let's go through the
conclusions real quickly
so they say assessing the consequences
of rule change in the game design
process demonstrate on chess
where we've trained alpha zero to
evaluate nine different variants
representing atomic changes to the rules
of the game training alpha zero model on
these rules changes helps us
effectively simulate decades of human
play in a matter of hours and answer the
what if question
what the play would potentially look
like under developed
theory in each chess variant
we believe that a similar approach could
be used for auto balancing game
mechanics in other types of games
including computer games
in cases when a sufficiently performant
reinforcement learning system
is available and yes this is
i mean this the application here would
be for something like this if you design
a new game then you want to know
what you have some choice with
how you can make the rules and you don't
want to
let humans become really good at each of
the rules and then compare
you can simply give this to the
algorithm and the algorithm will tell
you what kind of plays result from each
rule set and then you can choose the one
that you find
most interesting or most uh maybe
commercially viable
and what not i actually see this
much i see this bigger than just
games and this alludes a bit to the
salesforce
paper on this ai economist i think
we can let ai
you know get tell us what happens if we
change
for example uh things like tax policy
or any any sort of policy i know
humanity is very complex to model and so
on and you're never going to have a
perfect simulator which probably makes
alpha zero
not good but in limited situations like
maybe also stock trading rules and so on
you could definitely
have situations where the rule set is
too complicated
to solve analytically but you could give
it to an rl algorithm and see
what happens and whether or not you like
the outcome and whether or not there are
any
like obvious exploits that uh you
did not see so this i find
you know pretty it's it's a pretty cool
approach
and and we should think of this in the
future as we build systems
that have rules in whatever capacity be
this games or
policy so the they say
okay yada yada yada we showed that there
are several chess variants among those
considering the study that are even more
decisive than classical chess
meaning torpedo chess semia torpedo
chess no castling chess and stalemate
equals
winches we quantified a rising diversity
of opening play and the intersection of
opening trees between chess variations
showing how different the opening theory
is for each of the rule changes
yeah they again this this diversity
of opening play it really rests on this
assumption that alpha zero is a is a
good player and any
sort of an equally good player in all of
these variants right
because if it's worse in a variant it
might not be as sure about the moves and
that would just look like
oh you have many possibilities but in
fact alpha zero is just worse at it
and it doesn't know so they also look at
the intersection of opening trees
like if you change a rule how does this
change
um change the the kind of how does this
change the
the initial game so a lot of these
grandmasters they learn
by heart all of these opening trees the
initial moves of a game
how much would they have to relearn
there is a negative correlation between
the overall opening diversity
and decisiveness as decisive variants
likely require more precise play with
fewer plausible choices per
move again this is one view right the
other view
is that there are rule sets that are
just make it into a harder game and then
alpha zero given the same amount of
compute
is a worse player and therefore it can't
play as well
therefore the games are less decisive
and also the opening diversity is higher
because it doesn't know
if the game could be as decisive
it might just be an effect of alpha zero
for each of the chess variants we
estimated
yada yada okay no castling chess being
the first variant that we
analyzed has already been tried in
experimental blitz grand master
tournament in chennai
as well as a couple of longer grand
master games our assessment suggests
that several of the assessed chess
variants might be quite appealing
to interested players and we hope that
this study will prove to be a valuable
resource
for the wider chess community i
yeah i don't know is is the chess
community
flourishing or going under recently
because it seems to me like
it once once a game is solved that hard
by computers i mean it's still
fun but um yeah
i just i just i guess counter strike is
also
solved by bots real hard uh it's just
impressive when humans play or so
um yeah i don't know all of this is
again if you're into chess look into
this paper they have a lot of
really interesting results that are not
interesting to go
into for the general community but i
believe
this should give you a good impression
of what
you could do if you design a system that
is built
on rules all right so this was it for
this paper i hope you enjoyed this
if you liked it leave a comment tell me
what you think
and i'll see you next time bye bye